Here's my implementation of sense, the measurement model,
as a function in the class robot.
I produce a vector called Z, which I return in the end, which has 4 bearings.
Then I go through all my landmarks, and you already have the landmarks in your code--
--there's 4 of them--and I use the atan2 function,
which is the mathematical function for computing the angle.
It takes the y value as the first argument, and the x value as the second argument.
This is the local angle of a landmark relative to the robot coordinate.
Because the robot has a global heading direction,
I need to subtract this to get my bearing value.
If I were to add noise, which is a flag over here,
then I just produce a random noise adding variable.
This is something you shouldn't have implemented,
but you need later as you implement the noise.
Of course, I make sure that the bearing is normalized between 0 and 2π.
I append them to the list and return it.